I mean the golden gears of Hollywood on
the Warner Brothers lot I mean actually
on this stage I think Casablanca was
actually shot on this stage I mean think
about that that's that's Humphrey Bogart
and Ingrid Bergman we're right in this
space you know and now pretty much Ewan
and Andy come out every night and cut a
couple of forks
what the hell has happened to our
culture you're just Christ what the hell
is happened to me wait what am i 51
years old I'm still out here tap-dancing
for my supper I can't believe it blow my
head off
so always makes me want to do that show
on a Dutch suite whoa he looks like
Chuck Norris on a baby stupid baby yeah
sorry I'm not in The Hunger Games
whatever the hell that is what's
happened to you this is I drink
luckily I get my old friend Jack Daniels
here it's Jack Daniels barbeque sauce I
must not have had my glasses on it rats
it's cheaper yeah I'll tell you this
much I mean there's there's got to be a
little something-something in it they
can't call it Jack Daniels for nothing
yeah probably not no oh oh for God
[Applause]
[Applause]
you know okay you're right I'm not
getting buzzed you know they also they
didn't shoot Casablanca in here oh thank
god well what did the Goonies the girl
[Music]
[Applause]
this is where your show we are his hand
and glove with the show now let's talk
about I'm sorry you want to interrupt oh
that's good oh my god stop medicine ego
heart ego heart I've got a full
disclosure I'm involved a little bit you
why well your production company you
know el Coco Loco or whatever the hell
it's called producers it and you you are
the executive producers no which I'm
very grateful for it no it's a great
show it's on Adult Swim it's one of the
first things I've done since for a long
time that that I think actually captures
whatever the hell it is that I do I'm
very happy way that we have a great new
season we got a great group of guest
stars we have bud cort who's going to be
on the show and Ben Stiller does
something on the show and Dean Norris
from Breaking Bad and I believe mr.
Conan O'Brien does a little something
I wasn't I wasn't around for your
shooting your scene I don't know when
wouldn't do that
but why wouldn't you come by and see the
master at work yeah I heard it went very
long oh okay we hopefully it didn't get
cut I think I think you're right prick
yeah not a nice person
yeah we have a clip here from Eagle
heart I want to make sure we show this
little something from next season so we
just let it roll yeah I think it's
self-explanatory
you got 20 minutes booth I didn't order
any food hey well I don't know nothing
about that but this is the address that
gives me put on the desk and get out of
here oh no can do no I got a C's you
take a bite otherwise I don't get paid
sorry new management new rules a taste
and then you go okay sure yeah just a
taste
yeah
you
[Applause]